hello to all the marvel fans in china
i'm kevin feige president of marvel
studios
2020 has been an unusual year for all of
us but together
we've kept hope alive in the face of
unprecedented challenges
and we've never stopped telling the
tales of heroes
next year marvel studios will continue
to bring inspiring stories to the big
screen
including black widow shanghi and the
legend of the ten rings
as well as eternals welcoming a brand
new era in the marvel cinematic universe
before that there will also be a marvel
themed musical performance
to welcome the new year tune in to the
billy billy new year's gala on december
31st
and get a glimpse of what's to come in
2021
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder today the president of
marvel studios kevin feige had a message
for marvel fans over in china
and in this message that you just saw
kevin feige actually teased a few things
here
not only did he tease a new marvel
themed musical performance that is
coming on billability to celebrate the
new years but most importantly he teased
a look of what's to come
in the marvel 2021 lineup and he
specifically mentioned black widow
xiangxi and the legend of the ten rings
and the eternals
now for those of you who are wondering
about spider-man he didn't mention
spider-man because
that's also part sony all of these
projects that he mentioned marvel has
full control over but spider-man of
course they have that deal with sony
worked out but this announcement
is actually really good news as far as
spider-man is concerned as most people
know by now a sony executive promised a
first look at spider-man 3 before the
end of the year
that first look is widely believed to be
on christmas day december 25th although
that is not officially confirmed by sony
yet
but this announcement is a very good
sign because this announcement means
that marvel studios is going to be
showing
teasers for their other 2021 projects
black widow
shanxi and the eternals before the end
of the year as well which means it looks
like they're going to be showing
previews of
every single mcu movie coming in 2021 by
the end of this year so we've heard from
sony that they're going to give us a
teaser of spider-man 3 by the end of the
year but now marvel studios is backing
that up in their own way as well given
as teasers for other movies now it is a
little bit unclear of what kevin feige
is going to show here we know that the
eternals trailer is done we know that
it's been done for a while because they
actually showed footage of it at ccxp
last year now they may not show us an
entire teaser trailer for the eternals
but they could give us a little bit of
footage in our first sneak peek
the same could be said for shanghi the
filming for shang chi has wrapped it's
been done for a little bit now actually
which means the editing process should
be well
along the way especially since shengqi
is going to be coming out july 9th of
next year which means they could be
giving us a little bit of a teaser for
shanxi as well
and as far as black widow is concerned
there was a rumor that we were going to
be getting two new trailers for it
perhaps we could be getting one more
trailer by the end of the year
during this presentation that kevin
feige is talking about although at this
point in time i feel like we've gotten a
lot for black widow and we don't really
need more until the movie comes out
but we'll see on that but of course
spider-man 3 is coming december
17th of next year we officially have
less than a year till spider-man 3
releases
and again since sony promised us a first
look and since
marvel is kind of promising a first look
as well by the end of the year
it looks like we should be getting at
least an official title
for spider-man 3 within the next week
week and a half
hopefully again sony did promise that
first look
and now marvel looks like they're giving
first looks as well so hopefully by the
end of this year we'll get a new
teaser for the eternals for shanghi and
the legend of the ten rings and
our official title and first look at
spider-man 3.
and hopefully that first look shows not
just one spider-man not
two but three confirming the
spider-verse
as kevin feige mentioned 2020 was not
what we expected but hopefully we can
end on a really really good note getting
new teasers for each of these movies
that we are all
super excited about so don't forget to
subscribe with notifications turned on
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news concerning these teasers
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway which is a modoc funko pop from
the avengers game picking a winner on
friday
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof